what's happening reject nation you might
have seen earlier today that we posted
uh or like a one-minute quick thoughts
right after watching the first episode
for falcon the winner soldier disney
marvel sent that to us because we
actually
this morning did an interview with the
director that i
cannot wait to share with you guys we've
been doing some interviews lately and
this is probably my favorite one so far
yeah i can't say anything too specific
it was only
social media embargo lift today not
review
what i can tell you though without
ruining anything
just from seeing the thumbnails on these
two clips that they released while we
were doing our interview just from
seeing
the thumbnails we have not seen this
footage yet
during our discussion afterwards we'll
probably have to keep it short and tread
lightly
to make sure we don't get in trouble
with anyone because last thing i want is
getting in trouble with disney marvel
to be assassinated by kevin feige
himself
so yeah i dropped them both into final
cut then i hit export so i was just
watching back to back
well i don't trust red wings you don't
have to trust
red league but i'm gonna go see if he's
right
it's not a feeling they might be a part
of the big three
what big three w3
androids aliens and wizards
no it's not every time we fight we write
one of the three so what are you
fighting around
how do you know about gangnam i read the
hobbit in 1937
when it first came out
[Laughter]
a sorcerer is a wizard without a hat
right i just i just came up with that
it's crazy but look that's not the point
these guys aren't magical
all right they use brute force just like
you the incredibly annoying guy in front
of me with the staring bra
see that silencing cap is back
oh dude
what
foreshadowing the staring scene in
therapy from the trailer
great so no plan
30 seconds enjoy your ride
no you can't call me that why not steve
knew me longer and steve
that's the plan okay
that was cool love seeing their
interaction not wait to see more of the
show man well say is like
what surprised me is like i get why they
put these clips out you know because
this hones in more on what the trailer
is talking about or at least
demonstrating this is what they brought
with the director the trailers show like
the action a lot
and the humor the banter like the back
and forth which is what you're getting
here just in with more breathing room
because they're actual clips
and i think what was really the most
impactful part that
like in our post discussion when you
assume we put up our reaction the first
episode is actually how rich in
character it is and how much the show
really takes its time definitely slower
but it's more like the pacing of
something like winter soldier uh where
it takes its time a lot more it's more
deliberate
but there's some real rich character
exploration like you'll
you you'll get the cool [ __ ] like like
you'll get the cool [ __ ] and you'll get
some funny scenes yeah you will
but the stuff that really left us
impacted was
all the other things that are not as
strongly honed in on in the marketing as
of late and
that's the stuff i think will keep you
truly emotionally hooked
yeah into all this because i love their
chemistry here
and i love that you're gonna see
completely different shades of both
falcon and bucky that you didn't get to
see before some stuff
i know what they're talking about some
stuff i don't know yet
shredding lightly but but yeah i thought
that this did nicely to hone in on their
dynamic because two you know bucky and
sam up until this point have been very
much support
characters and characters that go to
enhance steve in a lot of ways and so
i think also too with like the marvel
sense of humor that we've heard about
these shows are exciting because not
only can they flesh out the backstories
of the characters and make them more of
real people to us but i think the comedy
also stands a chance to get that much
better
because it makes the difference between
putting a joke in versus just having
character
humor arise this got me yeah just
further excited for like so much of yeah
not getting too much into thoughts on
the pilot but you know just the takeaway
i was so
dazzled by you know the intrigue and the
action and all that stuff but to see
this side again
and to kind of get that anticipatory
element of like man i can't wait to see
the fun that's in store along with all
the
more intense and more rich stuff like
this show seems like it'd have
the whole package in a totally different
way from one division and yet while i
was thinking like
the show's not going to be as like
outwardly fun as one division i i could
see a potential for that honestly i mean
yeah the show is here just with their
chemistry alone
absolutely i think that thematically
what you'll get from these guys is a lot
more than just the fun yeah
they said thematically there's a lot
that deals with things like
self-worth more than just having to take
up like the mantle
uh themes of identity like they set them
up for rich character arcs too
you can see like the necessity of their
relationship and bond you're gonna get a
lot more than just the fun stuff guys
like this like
you're gonna get this this cool stuff
but i also love like the commentary here
just off this clip below when they're
talking about
you know the androids wizards and aliens
and you know it's funny like with there
were people
who seemed a little bit weirded out or
perturbed by the fact that there were
witches now in one division and then
we're like guys we've had it's just
we've had wizards with doctor strange
and they're like which is just like a
male witch
yeah and witchcraft are not very far
apart
so i love too that i've been hearing
like that's not most people's complaints
but i've definitely heard this
it seemed kind of strange to introduce
it in one division and i love that
following this up
you have bucky himself being like wizard
sorcerers what
i mean like they're different you know
yeah like
technicality kind of resembling some
minor fan complaints
that's the thing too is that they're
always i think getting better and better
and better at going we know what you
guys are talking about
you know and it's gonna be interesting
watching in the context of knowing that
this was supposed to be the first show
that came out and then wanda vision and
the fact that they're dropping stuff
like sorcerers and all that
yeah even if it's just in like the
comedy banter uh
um like wondering if they're doing
anything that could possibly have been
like oh
this is this was supposed to be setting
us up for something like wanna be yeah
yeah
yeah but looking back with the context
around it it's gonna be interesting
anyway guys falcon of winter soldiers
cannot wait for you guys to start this
show was
really really loved it really loved it a
lot best falcon action scenes you'll see
subscribe click the notification bell
keep a lookout for a reaction of that
last but not least
robert gunderson robert g my friend this
is disney plus show
i know that he loves disney plus because
they're going to be playing all these
star wars shows and this guy's a real
star wars nerd
actually reads like the books and all
that [ __ ]
my gosh okay now john add on because he
hasn't replied to me in a month because
he's busy
reading plate just right say the same
when you could be
talking to us making us feel loved you
talk about
toxic fandom over here jeez man stop
ignoring
us we just want your attention and we
need a new car could you please help us
out with the car salesman car sales
establishment's last shout out and then
we gotta go even further back could you
start working for amazon again
want to get some free stuff and it would
make it void
of you not talking to us a little easier
because if there's one thing you can
replace human connection with it's
stuff dude come on work with me here
somehow
rg we did it thank you for being part of
our patreon page buddy
[Music]